yesterday Donald Trump told what might
be the biggest whopper about the virus
so far and he's told many whoppers
during his press conference yesterday
and the day before Donald Trump has
again but played the role of someone who
is pretending to have been on top of the
virus since day one despite the fact
that he's ignored it and downplayed it
and lied about it
since the beginning here's what Donald
Trump said two days ago I just say this
we have an invisible enemy we have a
problem that a month ago nobody ever
thought about nobody in a you know I've
read about it I read about many years
ago 1917-1918 I've seen all of the
different the different problems similar
to this that we've had this is a bad one
this is a very bad one this is bad in
the sense that it's so contagious it's
just so contagious and then again
yesterday Donald Trump said well I don't
I don't number one determine recession
but I just say this we have an invisible
enemy we have a problem that a month ago
nobody ever thought about nobody in the
you know I've read about it I've read
about many years ago 1917-1918
I've seen all of the different the
different problems similar to this that
we've had now first of all Trump himself
was briefed about coronavirus two months
ago so even people in his administration
we're thinking about it two months ago
and brought it to Donald Trump
then you merely need to look at the list
of Lies that Donald Trump told about
this to understand the sort of
weaponized ignorance that we are dealing
with here we're putting a long list on
the screen
a few highlights on February 24 Trump
said the situation is under control on
February 26 he said coronavirus is a flu
also on that same day saying cases in
the US are down to close to zero
obviously couldn't have been more wrong
as we now have you know almost 10,000
diagnosed and and probably half a
million in total February 28 Trump
suggested an immigration link to the
virus on March 2nd from said a vaccine
is coming soon it's not on March 4 Trump
tried blaming it on Obama saying Obama
impeded testing and that is
not true and then countless times Trump
and others claiming that there's no test
shortage that we have tests that anybody
can get tested and on and on and on you
all know it consider that two months ago
Joe Biden wrote an op-ed criticizing
Trump's response to coronavirus that was
two months ago consider that we at the
David Pakman show weren't particularly
early on this and we covered it only
when it reached the u.s. on the
broadcast show we talked about it
earlier on the bonus show that was
January 30th that's almost two months
ago at this point so when Trump says
nobody knew nobody heard of nobody
imagined all he means is he didn't know
about he didn't take it seriously he
didn't care he said it with category 5
hurricanes I don't know if you remember
but at some point in the last year I
think it was Trump said when we were
facing a category 5 hurricane who's even
heard of a category 5 hurricane there
had been multiple category 5 hurricanes
under his presidency when he said that
so he had like a minute during which he
seemed more sober and serious three days
ago or two days ago during a press
conference he's back to calling it the
Chinese virus he's back to blaming
anybody that he can he's back to
bragging and raiding his performance as
a 10 out of 10 that's what we're dealing
with today we're going to have to solve
this
despite Trump but that being said it's
still good that he's saying it's serious
because a lot of these ignorant people
particularly with ignorant red state
Republican governors who continue to go
to the beach and go to concerts and
pretend like everything's fine
they will prevent us from dealing with
this as quickly as we can make sure
you're following the david pakman show
on instagram at david pakman show
we'll have polls and data and questions
about this there and while you're on
Instagram follow me at David Pakman
check out the excellent YouTube channel
we're partnering up with called up flip
you can get there at david pakman.com
slash up flip the link is right
underneath this video make sure you
subscribe while you are there up
flip is a YouTube channel that looks at
entrepreneurship in a very interesting
way their content looks at small
businesses what makes them successful
each video you get to meet a new
entrepreneur get a behind-the-scenes
look at their daily grind learn their
philosophy learn their business as a
business owner myself as someone with an
MBA I love watching the content there's
a ton of really useful insight to come
away with from every episode I love
hearing what the entrepreneurs share you
get practical advice they talk about
outside the box strategies and even if
you don't own a small business yourself
I think you'd be fascinated by the
content on up flip perfect for people
who like shows like Shark Tank and that
sort of thing get to the up flip YouTube
channel by going to david pakman.com
slash up flip the link is underneath the
video there friends of the david pakman
show definitely make sure to subscribe
to their channel click that Bell icon on
their page so you'll be notified
whenever they upload a new video